[Music]
Hello everyone, welcome. So today we'll
be talking basically about CISO approved
uh agent fleet architecture. So um my
name is Lou. I'll actually jump actually
jump into that actually. So my name is
Lou. I am a field CTO at a company
called Gipod. um in a past life you know
for for many years basically software
engineering on platform engineering is
my background but for the last four
years actually nearly four years I've
been working at GitPOD effectively
building uh a platform for automated
development environments
what I'm going to talk about today is
actually the journey over the last even
extends beyond my my tenure at the
company for the last sort of six years
building our sort of product
infrastructure and architecture for
secure environments particularly around
regulated industries and that kind of
thing uh I assume they'll probably in
fact actually I think I'm I'm already on
the next slide. Um yeah so in terms of
like who this talk is for um so
different aspects so first aspect is
really about how do we start to think
about how technical architectures of
product affect our business if you're a
vendor this is obviously something for
you uh there are probably a bunch of
people here as well that are either
building or consuming or thinking about
AI tools maybe also in these secure
environments but then also if you're a
buyer of this as well I think this this
talk will also be interesting if you're
buying using or consuming AI tools
thinking about like what architectures
might be right for you and what
considerations you might want to uh take
throughout that process.
So let's go ahead and actually just jump
into it. So for a little bit of context
um it's very hard to talk about this
talk without actually giving a bit of
background to the company and what we
do. So uh GitPOD is basically a platform
for secure dev environments. Um a lot of
people sometimes mix this up with things
like staging or integration environments
things like that but to give you an idea
like developers actually work inside of
git pod for around 37 hours a week 36 37
hours. So like you're it's almost like a
replacement I suppose like for your
machine or your laptop something like
that. So as a a consequence of that as
well it's highly mission critical
software. So if git pod goes down that
has a huge impact for our customers. So
it's really important that this is
incredibly reliable.
In addition to that what we effectively
do is because the automated aspects of
our dev environments we run also uh
mostly with uh highly secure regulated
organizations. So banks, pharmaceutical,
healthcare, uh a lot of the companies
that we work with as well like are quite
particular about like their logo rights
and publishing some of their names. But
for sure it's a lot of companies that
you will know a lot of household names
and things like that as well.
So as you can imagine building this type
of product then actually bringing it to
market is not an insignificant task
especially as you know if you're a
smaller company with sort of limited
resources trying to do that. Um, and in
addition to that as well, I'll talk
about this a little bit later, but we
actually launched and talk more publicly
about our agent offering um, two days
ago, but we've been building this for
for months with some of our design
customers as well. And I'll get on to
that and how how that uh, interfaces
with the architecture as well.
So, just as an overview and I will
actually deep dive into these a little
bit as we go through is um, we've gone
through various iterations of different
architectural models and they had
different implications for us as a
company but also for our customers. the
implications on for instance how much
ownership they have over those products
like the cost of running those products
uh and the security as well um of
actually when they run them. So very
quickly because I will actually deep
dive on these. So we started off 2019 uh
with a managed SAS product is where a
lot of products start host on the
internet multi-tenant you can go you
click on the website you swipe a credit
card you can use the product wonderful
but this doesn't work for secure
companies right so uh we went through
several iterations first with a very
self-hosted architectural approach uh we
then adjusted that and I'll talk about
exactly how and then we have what we
effectively have today which is also the
platform that we run our agent uh fleet
architecture on and we'll talk about how
that works as as well.
So, if we start at the beginning with
our sort of fully managed SAS, and I
don't know if you any of you know Sean,
but it's funny because I remembered this
tweet the other day um that he put out
several years ago is like GitOp really
inspired him to do, you know, a video
because it has a nice time to wow, which
is, you know, GitOp was very well known.
You click on a link and you end up in a
dev environment literally from from
oneclick interaction. Um, this was at
the time hosted on top of GCP Kubernetes
architecture. We chose GCP obviously for
the connection with Kubernetes. Uh and
the way the dev environments were then
orchestrated was pods running inside of
Kubernetes. So multi-tenant
infrastructure, but if you know anything
about Kubernetes, it's not really
designed for that type of workload. And
we will talk a bit about that uh as we
go on. But obviously there are several
challenges with this type of approach.
One, it's great to get started, really
easy to use your product, but we had a
ton of crypto mining and abuse on this.
It's one of these things like we can't
have nice things on the internet like
where we give away free compute because
somebody always wants to do something uh
always wants to abuse it effectively. Uh
but it's not also just insufficient for
enterprise. And one of the goals of Git
Pub is really to bring our product to
professional developers doing real world
real world work in uh in real companies.
So what do we do? What's the next step?
the obvious almost like the the logical
thing there is just okay well what can
we take our existing architecture take
that package that up as a self-hosted
installation then just give that to our
customers so we tried it uh we did do
exactly that we didn't think too much
necessarily about let's say the
specifics of cloud provider support so
we kind of open this up for Google I
think we had uh AWS at the time and some
of the others and you know we had all
manner of them requests from different
companies with all their different
flavors of Kubernetes and different
configurations to try and figure out how
We then self-host on those platforms.
In the fullness of time though, what
this came up with both for us as a
vendor but also for our customers is
significant day two effects. So self
self-hosting is great as a as a general
model, but it comes also with this huge
overhead. You typically have to set it
up, you have to run it and then as a
business also that ultimately is like
your cost of ownership. So uh as a
company like we're selling ultimately
selling a product to our customers. um
having a very difficult product to set
up and run is effectively eroding your
ROI. If you need to allocate two, three,
maybe even a whole team to actually set
up and run this infrastructure, then the
benefit that you're getting from that
product is also being eroded. The
difficulty with that as well is then we
don't have a strong relationship with
the people that are actually using or
running that product. That's also really
important, especially in an enterprise
sort of situation. How you adopt and
roll out the product can be critical to
its success. And often times we found
that you know especially in a
self-hosted model without support from
our side some of those people that are
trying to adopt the product also are
unsuccessful.
So considering that with the self-hosted
model uh what did we do next? So we we
looked at this ownership and this sort
of overhead uh challenge and said okay
we can solve this by effectively
providing what we called a substrate so
that we could allow customers to
self-host but then we could also manage
the service so we could take away some
of that overhead but in order to do that
we also needed to reduce variance. So
one of the things that we did is we
effectively doubled down on AWS as the
individual provider where we run the
infrastructure um but then we would then
manage it. So that meant small pieces of
telemetry data, other things that we
needed to in order to operate that
infrastructure were still being emitted
to us as a provider. But what it still
meant is the workload or in our case
source code, data integrations all still
live on the customer's infrastructure
which is then still ticking the box when
it comes to these regulated companies.
But despite this being a success,
certainly from an operational
standpoint, it still continued to have
effectively fundamental issues because
this still built on this sort of
Kubernetes-based infrastructure, still
highly complicated, let's say even when
you want to install. In this case, we're
running multiple clusters with a high
fixed cost, let's say, and also still a
lot of complexity.
This ultimately culminated in us moving
away from Kubernetes for our specific
use case. Um, I put this blog post up
because it goes into a lot of a lot of
detail specifically about why Kubernetes
was particularly challenging for us and
our use case and our workloads. Um, but
we decided to move away from that and
start to think from first principles
about what an architecture looks like
that solves this challenge of running
inside of regulated companies running
highly securely but doing so in a way
that doesn't create a huge operational
burden for our customers which is bad
for them and bad for us.
So ultimately this is actually the
architecture that we came up with and
that we have today that's also running
our AI agent fleet. So I'll just run you
through this real quick. So we have uh
what we call effectively like a runner
and if you're an engineer maybe you're
probably familiar with this like tools
like GitHub CI as well has like this
runner. The runner takes everything
that's secure. So in our case source
code and access to data and runs that on
the customer's infrastructure. A runner
is actually very very simple. In our
case, the runner is actually a single
ECS task. So, it's a single container
running and it obviously then costs like
we're talking dollars, single figures of
dollars to run uh every month. The core
workload that we spin up is then dev
environments. Uh each runner runs on a
different uh in our in our case this is
AWS, but if we you know for our Linux
runner, they are inherit the qualities
of the platform they're running on. So,
for AWS, we run workloads on top of EC2
and those are also then backed up to
EBS. So we can use the native
functionality and features of the cloud
provider to build that solution rather
than something like Kubernetes which is
theoretically portable but it also comes
with all of that overhead and complexity
of having the portability across
different platforms.
Then what we did is then also start to
think about okay so what are the things
that we can keep on our side as a vendor
so that our customers aren't taking on a
significant amount of operational
overhead. So a lot of that is like
metadata ids information about users
etc. not personally identifier
information, but like user IDs, like
stuff that if you were to get your hands
on it, it's not particularly significant
for our customers. They're not bothered
about losing that. They're bothered
about losing the IP, the source code,
things that's running actually inside
their infrastructure.
So, I did actually throw in a quick
video here because I'm going to turn off
the audio in this just to you actually
see what this looks like from a user
experience point of view. So this is
actually the user choosing their their
workload. When they choose those, those
those actually do run inside of their
network, inside of their their cloud
account to then set up and install on
their side. What we're able to now do is
provide them with this runner interface.
Creates a very simple cloud for ask the
customer to go through and actually uh
put in all of their different network
details. That bit is all on their side.
Create this. The process of running
this, it takes as little as 3 minutes.
The overhead or the challenge is usually
getting all of that network
configuration, VPC information, subnets,
finding out who in your organization
owns those, who can actually allocate
them to you. But fundamentally, this
makes it then exceptionally simple to
then deploy that for customers. And the
overhead of this then is also
significantly reduced.
Just one second.
Think I have to back out of this to
change over. There we go. Cool. So I
mean we're at an agent conference. So I
also presume I should certainly be
talking about AI and agents. So two days
ago I mentioned we basically launched
our uh agent offering which we've been
working on for months now since the
start of the year actually with
customers and our design partners. Now
because we have that existing
infrastructure already within those
customers, we can actually run the exact
same workloads. So because we create dev
environments, dev environments are
effectively for humans to be productive.
But everything that an autonomous agent
needs to operate is exactly the same
thing that a dev does. They need the
source code, they need access to
internal systems, whether that be an
internal database, a cluster, etc. So
when you give an agent the ability to
access source code and iterate, it can
do it inside of that same dev
environment with the same access and
privileges that an individual human
would as well.
because of uh like our target market and
the customers we go for that our agent
offering as well is also privacy first
because what we've effectively built
here allows us to um not only run inside
the customers infrastructure but there's
lots of other additional benefits that
come from that as well let's say things
like audit logs once we did that and
I'll just jump back a few slides once we
rearchitected to this architecture one
of the other first principles that we we
came back to is building this in an API
first way so every action interaction
when you spin up a dev environment And
everything that you do is then audit
logged and allows us to give our
customers also an entire sort of audit
history uh of the on the platform which
also then extends to once you start
running these workloads with agents you
also benefit from that as well. So that
audit log also runs for those agent
tasks.
What time is it? I have two more minutes
and the other guy is straight after. So
um that is a very sort of whirlwind run
through. We do have a booth downstairs.
I will be here and we we can dig into
this a little bit deeper if you want to
as well. Um I can show you how this
works in our context as well. But like
when you're then ultimately looking at
if you're purchasing other tools, AI
tools, these are the types of
considerations you want to make about
what is the architecture and
infrastructure and what sort of
different qualities they have. Um but
then also if you're a vendor as well,
there's probably a lot of learnings here
from our side that you can take from
this to build out a more simplified
effectively technical architecture. um
rather than you know building on top of
like difficult and complicated platforms
like Kubernetes and ultimately keeping
things simple for your customers as
well. That's it. Thank you very much.
Hope you enjoy the conference.
[Music]